all right you want to lose this last 5
to 10 maybe 15 pounds right that
stubborn fat that doesn't seem to want
to go anywhere whether it's in your
belly on your hips in your butt on your
thighs we're going to talk about this I
first want to show you this book right
here you probably heard of Sun Tzu
before this is called the technology of
War you may have heard of The Art of War
and I have a lot of different editions
of The Art of War but there's this guy
who translated
um Sun Tzu's original text
from the original manuscript he actually
learned Mandarin Chinese to translate
this book
and he found that there's been a lot of
alterations over the years he found that
the name of the book is not the Art of
War because the translation really
wasn't the word art art implies more
open ended creativity whereas technology
implies an exact way of doing a certain
thing so he actually found that the
actual name was the technology of War so
anyway this book is about a master
strategist and what he did to win so
many wars and a lot of the book is about
gaining advantages or creating
advantages so you can overcome
an opposition a problem or an opponent
versus just using force or working
harder at something doing the same thing
over and over and expecting a different
result so we're going to apply this to
weight loss so we first want to just
kind of briefly mention your
disadvantages let's say that your
menopausal you're getting older your
metabolism is slowing down you have
chronic insulin resistance you may have
atrophy in the muscles which makes it a
lot more difficult to lose the weight
because you need that muscle to help
with the burning of the fat so I'm going
to cover every single advantage that you
can use to overcome this problem but I
want to say something many times when I
talk to people they will tell me well I
already tried that it didn't work okay
and then you find out the way they were
trying it wasn't quite right so I'm
going to talk about that as well and
also some other times they were doing it
right they just didn't give it an
time they didn't know what normal was as
far as losing weight they thought
because my spouse loses seven pounds a
week and I only lose two pounds or one
pound per week then that means it's not
working in fact if you're losing over
two pounds a week you're just losing
water weight it's not actual fat and an
average person over the age of 40
if they can lose one pound a week that's
actually pretty good also you need to
understand the principle of it's not
lose weight to get healthy it's get
healthy first to then be able to lose
the weight because many times in the
process of getting healthy the body
doesn't necessarily lose weight first it
might get rid of the Cravings get rid of
your hunger help build muscle but the
body doesn't actually naturally like to
lose fat at all because fat is a
survival mechanism
so anyway you want to be able to do
something correctly long enough and
consistently enough so you actually see
results it's kind of like me with my
guitar teacher
um
he kept insisting that I go really slow
and I really learn to repetition the
patterns of my fingers right well in my
mind that's too boring it's too slow so
I actually practice a little faster
making all sorts of mistakes and I never
was able to achieve where I really
wanted to go with that so the key is
first knowing um what type of things you
can use to leverage this problem right
your leverage have certain advantages to
leverage the disadvantages just like
you'd have like a crowbar that you apply
like a five pound pressure to lift a 500
pound rock on something we want to do
the same thing with weight loss so let's
first start with
um doing the ketogenic diet right maybe
your carbohydrates just are not low
enough you want to go as low to zero as
far as carbohydrates as you can and I
have a video on that as well it's called
the keto and steroids I have another one
I will put both links down below but you
want to keep your carbs as low to zero
as possible the other problem I see with
keto is you may be doing a dirty version
of Keto not the healthy version makes a
big difference because yes lowering
carbs will help you lose weight but
having quality ingredients and making
sure those ingredients are really
healthy can actually help you lose even
more weight and get healthy at the same
time which is what we're trying to do
and also just because something on a
label says it's keto friendly does not
mean it's keto friendly okay and then of
course combining intermittent fasting
that is a necessity okay had one person
did keto but they didn't want to do
intermittent fasting so they were
basically eating High fat low carb keto
snacks through the whole day thinking
that they're gonna lose weight so just
because something is keto doesn't mean
you're gonna lose weight especially if
you're snacking or eating between meals
then let's get into the point of fasting
in a minute fasting how long are you
fasting for if you're up two meals a day
go to one meal a day okay if you're at
one meal a day maybe you have to go to
one meal every other day also a periodic
prolonged fasting is really going to
help you let's say on the weekends you
do a 48 hour fast let's say once every
two weeks or every month you do a longer
fast maybe even five days I mean that
right there usually will solve the
problem especially doing a lot of diets
or have very severe insulin resistance
however that being said I have some
people that do that and they still have
a problem so we're going to go through
some more things too so we have doing
the healthy version of the ketogenic
diet we have doing intermittent fasting
more aggressively and one thing I want
to mention about fasting if you're doing
prolonged fasting and you don't feel
good what that means is there's
something not right you should feel
wonderful when you do fasting I'm not
talking about when you first start out
and you're transitioning into the keto
fuel I'm talking about when you're
already adapted but you know you feel
tired you're hungry something's not
right in that case you're probably going
into it with nutritional deficiencies so
you better be taking electrolytes sea
salt a good amount you better be taking
B vitamins vitamin D maybe vitamin C and
you may even need if you're doing
prolonged fasting a really good amino
acid product so that way you don't have
the calories with actual protein
you just have the broken down amino
acids so your body can use that to
fulfill whatever need that it's trying
to fulfill and it's usually going into
fasting without having the right
nutrients
and many times it's just adding more
salt but very minimally you need at
least one teaspoon not a heaping but
just a level teaspoon of sea salt spread
out through the day we put in your water
that will usually make you feel a lot
better so those two things right there
will pretty much handle for most people
any stubborn weight but I'm going to
keep going and by the way as I go
through this I will put
a more detailed video on every single
topic that I'm talking about because I
don't want to make this video two hours
okay so we're kind of isolating what
area you need to focus on More by
covering all of them so then you can put
more energy into that Advantage okay
let's talk about sleeping some people
are sleeping but they don't feel rested
they're not waking up feeling
rejuvenated and I'm talking about if you
don't have a quality of sleep it's going
to affect your blood sugars it's going
to raise cortisol you should be able to
sleep and wake up and feel refreshed and
have energy through the day if you don't
have energy then we need to look at your
sleep by a ton of videos on this but I'm
going to put some down below that are my
most recent ones but as far as sleep
goes there's several things that can
help you sleep number one doing uh some
type of physical work around the house
outside primarily to get your mind off
the stress so stress is one of the
biggest Inhibitors of sleep doing a form
of exercise where you're really working
one or two muscle groups but you're not
working the whole body so you jack up
cortisol and your pulse rate is so high
where it can't come down because a high
pulse rate could keep you up at night
and then of course we have the
temperature being slightly cooler the
other thing is your room making sure you
don't have any extra light especially
not watching your computer screen or
right before bed or your cell phone
because that blue light can inhibit
melatonin we also have a few supplements
you should be taking before bed to help
you sleep like vitamin D is a good one
zinc is a good one and B1 is a really
good one even though B1 gives you energy
but it won't prevent sleep it'll
actually help you sleep because sleep is
an active thing it's not a passive thing
there's an there's like the Sleep
pressure that pushes you into these deep
delta waves that you're going through at
night to feel rejuvenated it's a
pressure that pushes you into the REM
sleep as well trying to sleep an extra
half hour or even an hour a day will
help you greatly even if you have to
take a nap all right next topic gut
issues if you have gut issues it's going
to be hard to lose weight because
typically if someone has a gut issue
they have a hard time with fiber so
they'll eat all these vegetables and
salad that I'm recommending and then
they end up like feeling bloated or
distended that is going to be a problem
so if you have gut issues you might want
to try more carnivore ketogenic than the
one with the fiber or probiotics I have
a very good video on that but we can't
have this bloating in your gut if you're
going to lose this extra five to ten
pounds I just want to touch on one
patient that I had who had a gut and
every time he went on vacation down to
Florida and later on the beach didn't
even change his diet but the lowering of
the stress okay and the sleeping
helped his gut go down to I mean like it
was flat when he came back it was
bizarre so that would be the stress
factor as well as the Sleep Factor
so now let's bring up this topic of
stress right if you're going through
stress it's going to be a big barrier
right why because of cortisol cortisol
can jack up your blood sugars almost as
much as eating sugar because cortisol
turns even ketones and fats and protein
into sugar for that quick energy that's
why even the hormone name cortisol
another name for it is called glucose
corticoids and this is why people when
they take synthetic cortisone or steroid
end up gaining a lot of weight because
of what it does to your blood sugars in
fact it can cause diabetes because it's
elevating your blood sugars so a couple
points with stress okay physical work
around the house out in the environment
long walks in nature vital taking more
B1 important also ashwagandha is a great
herb and it acts as an adaptogen so it
helps you tolerate stress much better
vitamin D will help lower your stress
greatly but
um just from the topic of stress when
I've worked with people for many many
years sometimes those people that have
really stubborn weight are just so darn
serious the intensity of trying to lose
weight and the stress of it is keeping
the adrenals revved up so I told one
lady okay who's doing everything right
just to stop worrying about losing
weight okay stop weighing yourself on
the scale just relax don't try to lose
weight so hard do everything in your
life that is
non-serious okay
and um just keep a real light attitude
I swear when she came back the next week
that was the only time she lost weight
that includes stop watching the news
stop watching things on the internet
that rev up your adrenals have a relaxed
a Carefree attitude all right next topic
pre-existing health conditions so many
people are on medication so many people
have health conditions that's the area
that you need to address I have a video
on every single possible health problem
that you might have do a search find out
how to address it naturally and try to
resolve that if you have some type of
condition that's inflammatory you need a
lot of vitamin D okay and that can drop
the inflammation and drop the
complications of that problem especially
if it's an arthritis and autoimmune
problem and that can help you lose
weight right there another barrier
the health of your liver if you have a
fatty liver okay
you could be doing things right now to
speed up removing that fat off your
liver because the more fat off the liver
the more weight you're going to lose all
the fat on your body has to go through
the liver and if it's all gunked up with
fat or cirrhosis or inflammation that's
going to slow down your progress the
best thing to take for a fatty liver in
addition to what I've talked about like
keto and intermittent fasting is to take
tadka as a supplement twice a day an
empty stomach and choline a few times a
day most of those will help speed up the
dissolving of the fat and it also will
help manage your cholesterol levels as
well in the food that you eat right we
want to eat food that
has energy in it the more processed
something is the more cooked something
is the less life it's going to give your
body so cruciferous vegetables are just
loaded with energy and life but let's
say for example you steam them right if
you steam them some of them will be
easier to digest if you ferment them you
enhance more life to that vegetable why
because now we have all these microbes
that actually are giving you all these
additional benefits to that food so
that's giving more life to the food more
life to your body the same thing with
the food that you eat if it's grown on
soils that are just dirt which means
void of microorganisms and you eat that
food that's grown on that you're only
going to reach a certain level of Health
it's not going to be very high and so
when you really look at it the health of
your body is dependent on the fertility
of that soil which is basically the
density of microbes that are mobilizing
these minerals that are not alive like
they're rocks so you need the microbes
to mobilize that to pull into plant so
then the animal eats that and you eat
the animal and you're eating something
healthy it'll actually give you more
Health all right what about bad genes
right you have genes that are keep you
fat well
you got to pick your parents more wisely
next time and I'm just being very
sarcastic but there are things that you
can do that can help influence the genes
it's called epigenetics it means above
your genes for example a lot of things
I've already mentioned fasting keto
reducing stress are all things to help
support these Gene actions that you want
right and avoid the other ones but
there's other things you can do these
are called hermetic factors that add a
little bit of stress not too much just a
little bit to cause your body to get
stronger and that would be of course
exercise prolonged fasting but also cold
therapy taking a cold shower can
actually stimulate Brown fat and
increase your metabolism and help you
lose more weight you can also do the
same thing with a sauna treatment that
can help you get the edge and give you
more advantage over this problem and so
what we're trying to do is to give you
multiple advantages to actually achieve
the goal now another hidden barrier
which keeps you at a certain set point
is chronic insulin resistance so there's
many things you can do to improve that
in addition to the things I just said
which will improve it you can take
regular apple cider vinegar it'll make a
big difference just with all your water
you just add a teaspoon of apple cider
vinegar and if you add cinnamon in there
or just take a cinnamon as a capsule
that can also help your blood sugar
significantly as well as make insulin
more sensitive berberine is a very
powerful herb that can mimic metformin
to help speed up the results of insulin
resistance and of course exercise is
another thing that can help it and
vitamin D can help it there's many
things on this topic I've done a more
extensive video and I will put it down
below all right so now let's talk about
exercise here's the thing exercise is
responsible for like 15
of this problem okay but 15 percent
could be the difference between success
or failure diet makes up the majority of
the weight loss okay now there's two um
types of fat primarily you have the
visceral fat in the gut okay and you
also have the superficial fat which is
just below the layer of skin right and
so women have more of a superficial fat
layer especially in the hips thigh and
buttocks and that type of fat is a bit
less influenced by insulin resistance
so if they do the usual things that I'm
mentioning with insulin resistance they
don't normally see the significant
impact like they do mainly in their uh
midsection which is the visceral fat
which is more influenced with insulin
resistance okay so that's why all these
other things will will help that in fact
that's easier to get rid of Than The
Superficial fact but exercise can be
more of a tool for that than anything
else why because it's going to build up
more muscle mass to give you more
metabolism right off the bat especially
if you have atrophy and especially if
you're postmenopausal so the other thing
about exercise is that there's some
mistakes that you can make
exercising over soreness that's really
bad that's over training that'll keep
you from getting results I had a patient
who exercised six hours a day seven days
a week that was her biggest problem as
soon as we reduced it boom she lost
weight I had a patient who was a guy who
was exercising seven days a week I got
him to work out one day a week and he
started to lose weight so over training
is an important thing don't ever
exercise over soreness the other point
is doing enough exercise to create a
stimulus to make sure these muscles grow
okay and so you want to use enough
volume and exercise to create that
effect how do you know if you're doing
it right well the next day you're sore
not just the next day the next three to
five to seven days that would be the
right amount of exercise and that's how
you can judge it and then you just let
your body go into that process but what
I mean by soreness and I'm talking about
let's say your legs are sore but your
upper body is fine so maybe the on the
other day as you're working the upper
body so you kind of divide up the body
in maybe three different sections maybe
you're working your chest and your
shoulders one day and then your back and
your abs another day and then your legs
the next day and that way you can create
soreness and then you want to let your
body fully recover this way you're doing
it correctly and then you need to do it
consistently long enough to have it work
so I want you to type down below what
you think you need to focus primarily on
on all the things I talked about
and then come back after you've done it
and report your progress but this will
definitely work if you haven't seen my
recent video on Plateau that probably is
another one to watch too because I get
more into the details of the food check
it out I put it up right here